it's in freefall zoom sale I was ever
kind level is all this for pie secret
don't die fine for a sort neon spike
fall little bottle run
[Music]
Oh Oh God maybe a range of characters
all we need for this one carrying two
little kids with me seems like a bad
idea
oh oh I can win can I win I don't know
back back back back back back back back
I think yeah you you went backwards into
yourself and I'm gonna rude Oh
easy peasy neon ball throw ball it's
gonna leave me alone for a second there
I love it when I get it into three balls
come on come on oh come on not the ball
the fall okay I guess I'm four oh I saw
those lame I oh I saw those bikes No
okay slide on your butt push somersault
I like it I like your spunk oh yes this
is the stuff this is the stuff of
legends right here yes mr k i don't know
what that means but apparently we're
going into a multi college level of doom
go go go go go fast oh come on don't
kill the babies do not kill the babies
okay we came back to me I'm gonna get
that landmine they're 100% impossible
apparently what these moves sick bro oh
the best look at me oh yeah understand
my boy epic Paul throw epic big ball
throw
stop laughing at me Santa so far so good
this lobster course secret passage hell
yeah
Oh God all right I'll play your game you
rogue Oh ah there we go
okay carrying on our merry way well what
now you ain't got nothing on me I'm
still carrying on Oh so delightfully
what is that the body of my son like I
give an ass do Kenny's you do realize
that then has the power of white so you
could have gone over it and not lost
your head oh all right well well well
well well well well well well well well
well well my leg all right bring it on
bring it on you squigglies Oh No
oh how am I going to ever get in the
ballet if my leg is through this box I
know what I know - I'm movie well I've
never played by your rules you know oh
my oh yeah oh look that is flying
whoopee do you could just pick it up a
little bit fantastic go back awesome
level wait for the screen okay up and
like that then we go backwards now we're
gonna go bit aah jet rise what is that
what does that mean Bob oh oh
Doh not a jet fall is what you're
talking I need to not go tremendously
quickly so that I get what you're saying
I'm buying what you're selling I'm
picking up what you're putting down the
pedal do for falling is death penalty
for failing is dead let me just retrieve
my stuff let's we retrieve my okay to
everybody that that was just a test to
scare you that was also just to scare
you all right get out of my way we don't
that would be cool oh come on how about
we don't die yeah son you take all these
blades you shove them up your butt and
then we will continue to be alive okay
okay good job everybody go home now ooh
this would be god dammit
can you make it I don't know I haven't
seen the level yet can I make it
[Music]
oh come on oh come on 100% em pop oh my
god
okay this time I may have underestimated
this one just a week Smiley's revenge
well looks like it's time to
[Laughter]
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you liked the
video and want to see more why not
subscribe today want to help the channel
grow leave a like
add it to your favorites will share with
your friends on Facebook and Twitter
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
now that I have a tail I'm one of you
guys right let me just crawl my way
forward I'm coming buddy hey now that
I'm in hell what does this mean for Ross
a me like do I get a job now or do I get
employ man or maybe you give me
something to get revenge and all the
people that screwed me over in life oh I
see you're twirling your stick what if I
twirl my tail - like this I like your
dance moves bro ha ha ha ha ha ha the
raining blood is a nice touch I really
like it whoo oh oh that really hurt you
seem to have disabled my ability to
dance well I got the blood raining on me
so it's not so bad in all honesty it's
it's pretty good I like your tan Tanner
your can can it's nice hey how about you
and me go good